Stearns:
My name's Geoff Stearns.
I work also
on the syndication team.
I guess you're hearing
lots of people
from syndication today.
I primarily work
on the video player.
So normally
when you would see
a YouTube video,
uh, on a Web site
that is not YouTube,
it's probably
playing back
in one of the players
that I work on.
So we have
a few different players.
I think you've heard
a little bit about them.
I'm gonna talk about two players
in particular.
One is the standard
embedded player,
which is probably the one
that you're all familiar with
and the one
that you've seen,
you know,
around on the Internet.
And then the chromeless player,
which has probably
been mentioned
a few times today already,
which is our sort of super
customizable player.
So let's get started,
I guess.
I guess first of all
I wanted to talk
a little bit
about the embedded player.
Now, the chromeless player--
Uh, well, let me back up.
So the embedded player
generally, I feel,
would probably be okay
for probably 99%
of your needs,
in my opinion.
The chromeless player
is exciting and all,
but the embedded player
really brings everything
together.
So the embedded player,
you guys have all seen it.
Let me show you
a quick example of it
just to show
a little demo here.
Oops, I already
have this open.
So this here
are a few examples
of videos embedded
using our embedded player.
And you can see there's
a couple different layouts
and color options
you can make.
We can even watch
a couple videos here
that are pretty funny.
Do we have audio?
Yes? No?
There it goes.
Yeah, I think
they just turned it up.
[techno rock music]
[video game sounds
of hitting and punching]
[shouting indistinctly]
[man growling]
[laughter]
So there's not really
a lot of point in that.
I just wanted to show it to you.
It's pretty funny.
Um...
The one thing
to sorta get outta this
is you can see that
with the embedded player
there's a lot
of customization options, okay?
You can set the color
of the control bar.
You can add a border
around it if you want to.
These down here, we sorta
call this the genie menu.
Although it used to look
more like more of a genie thing.
Now it's just sort of
a slide forward thumbnail menu.
You can enable this
or disable this if you want.
A lot of people ask,
you know--
I actually talked
to someone recently
who said they really wanted
to use the embedded player
but they hate how it shows
these related videos
that could be, like,
a competitor,
or it could be, you know,
a random spornography
or something like that,
and you might not want that.
And you can disable it.
So I'll go through
that stuff in a minute.
Um, a couple other examples
of videos
and just a couple of other
videos that are kinda fun.
So we'll watch those.
[jingling sound]
[man speaking foreign language]
[bottles jingling
"Mario Bros." theme song]
Stearns: Does anyone here
have this much free time?
No?
[man speaking indistinctly]
Yeah?
I'd volunteer
our parking garage
if anybody wants
to do this later.
All right, so let's take
a quick look at--
[audience chuckling]
Uh...
So let's take a quick look
at the options
that you have available
for the normal embedded player.
If you go to our YouTube site
on the code.google.com site,
we have a couple of pages that
relate just to the player thing.
So we have
YouTube player tools here.
There's a page
called "player parameters"
that talks about the different
customizations you can do.
And then we have
some JavaScript and Flash APIs
and the chromeless player stuff.
So this is, like,
your one resource place
for anything you want to know
about the players.
So quickly
I'll step through this stuff.
This is a list of all
the different parameters
you can use
on the player.
And a lot of people
sort of gloss over
or maybe don't realize that you
can actually customize them.
And it's really easy
to customize the player.
All you do is you go
to the YouTube site.
Just give you
a quick example here.
You pick the video
that you want.
Grab the embed code here.
And when you stick it
in your page,
or whatever you're
putting it into here,
all you have to do
is modify a few variables.
So you could notice
there's the URL to the player
in two places here.
There's this one here.
And this has
a few parameters.
Now this part right here
is the actual URL to the player.
And if you just use
that plain URL,
you'll just get
the normal standard player
that's just the gray that
you've probably seen a lot.
But all these other
variables here, uh,
are extra things
that you can customize.
And you can actually
come in and change these.
So like color one,
color two right here,
these are just hex values.
So you can set them
to any hex value you want.
Color two is the color
of the control bar,
and then color one
is the color of the border
or sort of like the secondary
color of the player
if you turn the border on.
HL is a language.
We support I don't know
how many languages.
Maybe 18 different languages
right now?
So you can actually
tell the player
to be whichever language
we support.
We're always adding
new languages.
I think by default
it's whatever user language
you used when you got
the embed code.
FS is a new one
that I haven't documented yet,
but I'll tell you guys
about that in a second here.
Um, so that's how
you edit that.
Let me go back
to my page here.
All right, so really quickly I'm
just gonna run through these,
'cause these are pretty useful
for most people.
So the rel argument is,
like I said earlier,
it's to turn on or turn off
the related videos
in the player.
So either when you push
the menu button
or when the video ends,
if you set rel to zero,
then you don't see
those related videos.
Autoplay just lets the player
autoplay when it loads up.
You guys can see certain sites
like Digg uses that one,
you load a video on Digg.
You can set it to loop.
So if you want to have a video
just loop forever,
you can set loop to one
and it'll loop forever.
All these values, if they're
like a Boolean value,
it's either one or zero.
So make sure you don't put
like "true" or "false" in there.
It actually has to be
a one or a zero.
Enable JSAPI and player API ID
are kinda special ones.
I'm gonna talk about those
in a little bit.
Disable KB just disables
the keyboard controls.
A lot of people don't know
that the players
have some keyboard controls.
They're listed out here.
So you can use spacebar
to play and pause the player.
Or you can use
your left and right arrow keys
to jump ahead or jump back
to the beginning.
And then up and down
arrow keys
change your volume
up and down.
EGM is kind of a weird one.
I don't want to spend
too much time on that.
But it basically
makes it so that
if you set EGM to one,
when you hover over
the video player
with your mouse,
it brings that little menu up
over the video.
So it lets you kinda,
I guess,
helps discoverability
a little bit.
The border one or zero
turns on that border
that's around the player.
And you can set that
on or off.
And then color one, color two
is what I already mentioned
for setting the colors.
And then there's a few other
example usage here.
And there's another example
of the video player
with a blue border.
So I think a lot of people,
they ask
for the chromeless player.
But really this player
is really, really flexible
and would probably suit
most of your needs.
And then this way
you don't have to build
your own control setup
since we already have our,
you know, pretty standard
controls already set up there.
Another thing to notice
is that this site--
this player also allows you
to set the player
any size you want.
So it doesn't have to be,
like, a standard 4x3.
You can actually set it
to, like, wide-screen
like the last video
I showed you guys.
Or you can shrink it
or make it bigger.
You know, pretty much
whatever size you want,
the player will just fill
whatever size you give it,
which is nice.
There's not a way to set
the quality yet.
Sorry.
Um, let's see here.
All right,
so let's go back.
So...
let me go back
to my examples here.
Oops.
All right, one more video
and then we'll move on.
This one's good.
So the FS parameter, actually
it's not documented yet.
But I added full screen
functionality
to the embedded player
last week.
So you guys can now
use your embeds.
If you just go and get
the new code from the Web site,
you can watch stuff
in full screen now.
man: A slightly larger balloon,
an 80 inch.
Stearns: It looks like
the projector's kinda
screwing it up
a little bit.
But really it should--
it would fill the whole screen
if it was
on a normal display.
man: I keep the rubber band
with me.
Stearns: This guy's name
is Billoon45,
and he's a balloon fetishist.
This was his second attempt
at trying to climb
inside of a balloon.
[chuckles]
Gunther likes this guy.
This guy is basically like
the patron saint
of the YouTube web developers
for the most part.
man: Oh, forgot the glasses.
They gotta come off.
Well, my head's inside.
Whoa.
Stearns: I think there's only
one end of it, I guess.
I think it's, like, a big
South American weather balloon
or something like that.
He actually tells you
what it is.
man: My arm.
My head's inside.
Whoa.
Darn it.
That's the last thing
I need now.
Not fucking cooperating.
Oh, great.
I'm becoming trapped
in the balloon.
Drat!
Oh, I hate this.
Oh, darn it.
Oh.
Blast it.
I can still breathe.
Hmm.
Hmm, I gotta get
out of this balloon.
[groaning]
Drat it.
Let's find me
a spot here.
[groaning]
Stearns: I think that's
my favorite part right there
when he does
the little shimmy.
man: I ripped the balloon.
Drat dog.
Hate that.
Stearns: This guy's awesome.
[audience chuckling]
This is fantastic.
All right.
He does a lot
of confessionals too.
I highly recommend his channel.
It's really good.
Um, it's Billoon45
is the name
if you guys
want to look it up.
So anyway,
so really quickly,
the full screen mode
that's there now,
any new embeds that you grab
from the YouTube site
should have
the full screen embed.
But you do have to do
a little bit of special stuff.
If you have, like,
an existing Web site
that uses our embed code,
you have to add
an allow full screen
parameter and attribute
to your embed code.
And if you guys want to see
what that looks like,
you can just grab any embed code
from the YouTube site
and you'll see it in there.
And then there's another
player parameter called FS.
And you set that
to either one or zero
to either show or hide
the actual full screen button.
So we do that because
a lot of our old embed code
didn't have the
"allow full screen" parameter.
So if we showed the button,
the button just wouldn't work.
So in some cases
we'll actually hide the button
on sites that don't support
the full screen embed code.
So have some fun with that.
Um, all right.
It's hard to think
after watching that video there.
Let's go back
to the thing.
All right, so another thing
that I want to talk about
is the JavaScript
and Flash API.
So in the embedded player
and in the chromeless player,
they both can support
a JavaScript API
for controlling the player.
And they can also support
a Flash API.
So if you're working
with ActionScript,
you can load the player
into your ActionScript app
and have pretty much
full control
over the players that way.
The APIs are pretty much
identical, with some exceptions
as to how you initialize
the player
when you load it
into a Flash app,
which I guess is probably
to be expected a little bit.
I want to
kinda briefly go over
the JavaScript API reference,
and I'll get more into this
a little bit later.
So the key thing
to know about, I guess,
for using the JavaScript API--
Let me actually
show the demo first,
and then we'll
get back into it.
So this is, like, a really quick
demo page I set up.
This is actually linked
off of the bottom
of the JavaScript
reference page
on the code.google.com site.
So this is just
a normal embedded player
embedded on a page.
And I have
some HTML controls here
that enable JavaScript
controls to the player.
So I can hit play,
and the player
will start playing.
You have pretty good
support over it.
I can hit pause.
You can mute it
or un-mute it,
which I think my sound
went away again.
But that's okay.
[rock music]
You can seek around
within the player.
So you can seek
to any time you want.
You can seek ahead to, uh,
say, like, 150 seconds.
So you can see ahead
to points in the video
that haven't loaded yet.
So if you guys have noticed,
YouTube uses sort of like
a custom streaming method,
I guess you would call it.
All of our videos
are progressive download.
But the way
that we serve them
is that we can actually
start playing them
from any point
in the video.
So you can actually
jump ahead in the video
and start playing points
that haven't actually
downloaded yet.
And it'll just make
a new request to the server
and start downloading it.
And you can see that happening
here where I jumped ahead.
Or I can, like, jump back
to here that hasn't loaded,
and it'll just jump
to that point and start loading.
So the JavaScript API
along with, you know,
just the player controls
give you access to that.
So you could actually
have a player that loads,
start playing it
from the middle of the video
if you wanted to,
and let it play, like, a segment
and then stop it
or whatever.
So you can do lots of really
fine granular control there.
And then you can
see down here
I have some numbers
being put out here.
So one of them
is the duration
where I grab the duration
from the player.
The other one is the current
time of the video.
So you can key events
according to how
the video is playing
and what the current time
in the video is.
You can also get
how many bytes have loaded,
how many bytes are total.
And then the start bytes,
which is, you know,
in the case where you
start it from the middle,
you can know
what the start bytes are.
So if you wanted to,
you could recreate
the seek bar here
using that data.
So you could have your own
custom seek bar or whatever
if you wanted to,
and that really comes into play
when you're using the chromeless
player for the most part.
There's also ways
to get and set the volume,
um, and mute it.
Uh, and I think that's it.
We'll go through that stuff
in a little bit.
So...
this is our JavaScript API
reference.
All the functions
are listed out here.
You have play, stop, pause.
I'm not gonna go
through all of them
'cause they're probably
pretty self-apparent I think.
Um...
Seek to--
One thing to note
when you're seeking with videos
is that the FLV format
has a limitation
to where you can seek to
in that you can only seek
to a key frame
within the video.
And if you're familiar
with video,
you know that there's not
a key frame every second,
or every frame even.
The key frames
are usually spread out.
And in my experience,
key frames on YouTube
are usually between
two seconds all the way up--
I've seen them as far apart
as 15 seconds unfortunately.
So we have been working
a little bit
on getting that
closer together
and trying to set up
a standard way of saying
any video should only have
key frames
at a maximum as far apart
as two seconds,
which makes seeking
a little bit better.
But in some cases,
with older videos that haven't,
you know, that were encoded
a long time ago,
you might see a little bit
worse performance in that case.
So that's something
to worry about.
If you call seek to
and say you want to go
to seconds--
like, 15 seconds
into the video,
and the first key frame
before that happens to be
at, like, seven seconds,
they player will always jump
to the key frame
before the time
that you requested.
So the user will always see
the content that you
intended them to see.
But they might see a little bit
ahead of that time as well.
And you guys could do
some trickery where, you know,
you seek to 15,
and if it doesn't go to 15,
you could, like,
hide the player
and mute it or something
until it gets to 15
and then show it.
So, I mean, you guys
could sort of hack together
a real sort of accurate
seek time thing.
The allow seek ahead parameter
is just the way
to allow you to either
tell the player--
allow the player to jump ahead
and make a new request
to the server
or only seek within the part
that's already downloaded.
So you can actually
genuinely build, like,
a seek bar that works
the same way that ours does.
Um...
Everything else here
is pretty standard.
Um, the add event listener
is the way that you listen
to state changes
in the player.
So when the player loads,
you can--
you can set up a listener
for this on state change event.
So any time
the player state changes,
like, if the user
plays it or pauses it
or the video ends,
you can listen for that state
and then act upon it.
So you can know
when the video ends
or if the user paused it.
You could also compare
the current time
to the duration
of the video as well
and find it out that way.
But the events are probably
a little cleaner.
And then
there's an error event,
which this only has
one error listed,
but there's actually two
different errors you can get.
One would be if the video
has been taken down,
or if it's now private,
or something like that.
And the other one
is if the video is, uh,
has embedding disabled,
which I believe
is a 101 error.
But I haven't updated
the documentation yet.
The way that this works
is when you load the player
in the page,
you have to add
a player parameter
in order to enable
the JavaScript API,
called enable JSAPI.
You set it to one.
And what this does
is it tells the player
that you want the JavaScript API
to be turned on.
And so by default
it's turned off
so we don't call
random JavaScript functions
on everybody's pages.
Once you call that,
when the player
loads on the page,
it's going to call
this function called
"on YouTube player ready"
which is mentioned right here.
Right here.
So what you do
is you specify this function
called "on YouTube player ready"
in JavaScript on your page.
Once the player loads, it calls
on YouTube player ready,
and that's how you know
the player is ready.
Um, there is a certain case
where if you have more
than one player on your page,
you might not know
which one is ready.
So there's another variable
called player--
"player API ID,"
which is right here.
And you basically just set that
to any string that you want.
It should be, like,
a unique string, obviously.
And what happens
is when the player then calls
on YouTube player ready,
it'll pass that string
back to that function.
So you know which
of your players is ready
and which ones
are still initializing.
Yeah?
[man speaking indistinctly]
Stearns: Um, so the--
Yeah, so the question is
is there a way
to stay in full screen
and jump from video
to video?
In the normal embedded player,
no, there's not.
There's no way to load
a new video at this point.
It is something
that I want to add,
but I don't know how long
it'll be until that's added.
With the chromeless player,
you could do that.
So in the chromeless player,
it doesn't have
native full screen
functionality that we do.
But if you load
the chromeless player
into your own SWF
and make that go full screen,
then you could load a new video
into the chromeless player,
and it would stay
in full screen,
and you could load
the new video.
So you guys could do, like,
a full immersive
full screen mode where they
never have to leave
and load whatever videos
you want.
Um, let's see.
So that's pretty much it.
There's a lot of other
example code on this page
to get you started.
And the demo that I showed
is down here at the bottom
where the sample stuff is at.
So let me show you
a couple other demos
using the embedded player.
So here's something
that I put together
after I made the API.
This was sort of inspired
by a mashup I saw a while back
on the Internet called--
It was using a video
called "Rendezvous,"
and it a guy--it's an old
classic video apparently
of a guy who races
through Paris
going really, really fast
in a car.
And somebody had taken
a Google Maps thing
and had planned out his route
and synchronized it
with the video.
Only it was, like,
fake synchronization
where you had to, like,
start the video
and then start the map
at the same time
and hope that
they were synched up.
So I did this video
as sort of--
kind of a parody of that,
but then also
sort of a showcase
of what you can do
with the embedded player API.
So what this does
is it takes this race
that goes down
a really twisty street here
in San Francisco,
and it sort of synchronizes
the guys' travel down the street
on this Google Map.
[crowd cheering]
So unlike the other mashup
that I had seen,
this one actually
synchronizes it with the player.
Since we're using
the player API,
we already know
where the player position is
when you're playing stuff back.
So if I back up here,
you'll see the map
will stay synchronized with it
and back up with it.
So I can actually drag this
and, like, jump ahead,
and the map will always
stay synchronized
exactly with where
the guy is in the video.
So this isn't real GPS data.
I wish it were.
That would make it
really cool.
I actually set up--
There's sort of like
a debug mode on the map's code
that I borrowed
from the other guy
where you can just kinda
click on the map in an area
and it'll follow
where you're clicking.
So you can, you know, plan out
the area you want to go to.
And then I just sort of manually
tweaked it a little bit.
man: Whoo.
Stearns: And if you view
the source of this page,
all the source is there,
you guys can look at it.
Uh, the URL's right here
if you can see that.
It's linked
on my presentation.
So if you grab
my presentation,
you can see it.
Okay, let's go back
to this here.
All right,
so here's another thing.
This was actually started
as, I think, a 20% project
of a Google engineer
down in Mountain View.
They wanted to have
a debate tool,
I guess you could call it,
where they wanted to watch
these presidential debates,
and then add
a sort of transcript,
and then also have a sort of
interactive feature to it
where, you know,
if a politician said something
in their debate,
you could look it up
and then, you know,
add the transcript later
saying, you know, "This
isn't necessarily accurate."
You know, "There might be
some other stuff here."
Or, you know,
"This is accurate.
And in addition,
here's some more information."
So there's a few different
videos here.
And you can actually pick one.
And you have this transcript
for the video
that goes along next to it.
And you can jump around
by either clicking here,
and you can jump around
the video.
Or if you just watch
the video,
this transcript will stay
synchronized the whole time
while you're watching it.
It's a pretty nice
use of it I think.
man: And especially Mexico.
Southern Mexico,
it was a disaster.
It destroyed the entire
agricultural economy.
Guess what happened,
they all came north.
If NAFTA had worked
so well as--
Stearns: Oh, my God.
Um, let's see.
And then this is
sort of the same idea.
This was, uh--
Michael Geary actually
came up to us at Google I/O
a few weeks back
and saw the demos.
And I think
he went home that night
and coded this into
a jQuery plugin the next day,
and showed up at our booth
and said,
"Hey, look what I made.
It's pretty cool."
So this is really neat.
This is sort of like
a presentation tool
where he took a video--
I believe he gave a talk
at Google a while back
about YouTube map mashups
where he did
some election maps
using YouTube Maps
and the maps API.
woman: All right,
so this is Mike Geary.
So I originally--
Stearns: So he made
this little tool.
And this is actually
a jQuery plugin
that you can take
and add a bunch
of pointers to your video.
And this is, you can see,
it's, like, an hour-long video
of the presentation.
And as it goes through,
this will follow along.
You can see it just
changed there on its own.
And then in this
big area here,
it actually loads in
a URL that you give it,
or it could load, you know,
it could load a slide
of your presentation
if you wanted it to.
Or in his case,
he actually loads
different HTML pages
and the actual Maps demos
that he's talking about
in the apps.
Like, if you look at
Iowa maps API map,
you can see
this actually loads
the thing that he's talking
about in the thing here.
And this is actually
a live Google Maps thing.
So you can move it around
and play with it and zoom in
and actually play with it
while the talk is going on
while you're listening
to the talk.
So I thought this was
a really nice use
of the player API.
And it always
stays synchronized
as the video plays.
And the source code
is all there.
I think it's anno two,
but I guess he called it--
And like I said,
it's a jQuery plugin.
So if you're using
jQuery already,
it's really easy
to get started and using it.
You just basically
set your stuff up and go.
Um...
All right.
So...
Um, the Flash API,
does anybody use Flash?
Anybody care about Flash?
Should I go over
the Flash stuff?
All right, there's
a good number of people.
So I'll talk about it
a little bit.
There's not really
a lot to talk about.
Everything that's in
the JavaScript API
that I mentioned is also
available in the Flash API.
So it's pretty much
the same thing.
The one caveat
is that our players
are written
in ActionScript 2.
I'm sorry.
But we do that
so we reach more people.
So I know all you guys
are probably using
crazy ActionScript three.
You can still embed the player
in ActionScript three,
but it takes a little bit
of extra work.
So you're probably familiar
if you're a Flash developer
that AS 2 cannot talk
directly to an AS 3 SWF.
So you have to write
some sort of wrapper
that uses either
external interface
or a local connection
to talk between the SWFs.
I've seen a few people do it.
I think this presentation--
or one of these demos
I'm gonna show does it.
So it is possible.
And there's
a lot of talk about it
on our GData API forum
if you guys are interested
in checking it out
and you want
to get on there.
Um...
The only difference really
with the Flash API
is how you load the player.
So you actually load it
into a movie clip,
and then you can call this
"is player loaded" call.
You basically have to set up
some sort of loop or something
that checks
until it's loaded.
And then when it's loaded,
it'll let you know,
and you can start calling
all the API calls.
Um, okay.
So the chromeless player.
The chromeless player,
I can actually claim
that I designed
the chromeless player.
The visual design, that is.
And that's because it doesn't
have a visual design.
All it has is a logo.
So to show you an example
of the chromeless player
I suppose...
[clears throat]
Here it is.
Ta-da!
Hold the applause, please.
No applause.
[laughter]
All right, so the idea
behind the chromeless player
was that we wanted
to give people
as much control
over our player as we could,
within reason obviously.
So we still want to add
all of our cool features,
like, you know,
annotations and things and--
Excuse me.
And all the fun stuff.
And also hopefully
make it easier
for you guys to develop
with our things,
with our videos,
I should say.
So the chromeless player
has all the same controls,
JavaScript controls,
Flash controls,
as the embedded player does,
only it doesn't have
all the extra stuff,
like, you know,
the related videos
and the color settings
and the control bar and things.
All right.
So, um,
that's pretty much it.
I want to show you guys
some demos
'cause I already have
this one up.
This one was
a pretty recent thing.
This was done
by a little agency
in, I don't know, I think
Philadelphia or something.
And this is for JCPenney.
And they did, like,
a little karaoke machine.
And you can actually
start singing.
And what it does is it--
They basically capture
their own video,
and it's a Flash app
obviously.
It's, like,
a full page thing.
I think it's actually AS 3.
And let's do
"Ballroom Blitz" I guess.
And it records you--
I guess it'll record me.
I don't know,
I'll have to like--
I'll have to scoot down here.
Oh, no.
Well, it didn't find
my webcam properly.
Whoops.
We don't want
to watch that one again.
man: Watch the balloon again.
Stearns: Yeah.
I'm gonna bring a balloon
to this thing next time.
Let me open that up again.
All right,
I'll just show you guys one
that somebody has made.
So what they do is they
basically record the camera
in their app.
They send it up to--
They can sort of transpose
and sort of--
I don't know, I guess
"transpose" isn't the word.
They can sort of mash up
all these sort of different,
uh, effects and things
that they've done
that are similar to, like,
what you can do in iChat
if you have the most
recent version of iChat.
And then they send it
to YouTube.
And then they play it back
using the chromeless player.
So this is the chromeless player
loaded into their app,
and then they have
their own custom UI.
You know, it's real simple,
just play/pause.
And then you can listen
to all these people singing.
So it's like
a karaoke app.
man singing softly:
And I ran.
I ran so far away.
Stearns: Yeah, not everybody
really gets into it as much.
man singing:
I couldn't get away.
Stearns: We could find
a good one I guess.
Let's find somebody good.
This guy looks like a pro.
[laughter]
Yeah.
man singing:
I'm all out of love.
I'm so lost without you.
I knew you were right
believing for so long.
in falsetto:
I'm all out of love.
I'm so lost without you.
I knew you were right.
Rachel, come back.
Ahh-ah-ah!
Get this thing
out of my face.
Stearns: Yeah, so--
[laughter]
So the way
that this works, I believe,
is they capture frames
of the video, or the video,
and then add their effects on
the client's side using Flash.
And all these effects
that you see,
like the stars
flying around things,
I think are actually done
in Flash
using, you know,
just random things.
And then you can do,
like, different stuff.
And you can actually
manipulate bitmap stuff
really well in Flash, so.
And then they take that
and they send--
they compile the video
on their server,
and then suit it up
to YouTube using the API
and then load it
back through the API
into their app there
and display it all.
So it's a really nice use.
I have a few other demos
of the chromeless player
that I want
to show you guys too.
If you're not up to writing
your own player that uses it,
there's a really popular player
called JW FLV player
that some of you
may have heard of.
It's pretty popular.
If you don't recognize
these controls,
you probably will see it around
the Internet at some point.
It's a really popular
just sort of really generic
FLV player that plays
pretty much anything.
And it's really, really
customizable.
So when I did
the chromeless player,
I told this guy about it.
And he was interested
to get the chromeless player
into his player.
So you can actually
use this player now
to play YouTube videos because
it uses the chromeless player.
[David Hasselhoff's
"Jump in My Car" plays]
So he chose also a really
awesome video to demo this.
Hasselhoff singing:
Jump in my car.
I want to take you home.
Come on and jump in my car.
It's too far
to walk on your own.
women singing:
No, thank you, sir.
Hasselhoff singing:
Oh, come on.
Stearns:
And you can see here
it's really customizable.
And you can go through here
and customize
pretty much anything.
You can auto start.
He actually has
a full screen option here too.
[man speaking indistinctly]
Stearns: No.
man: Too much of it.
Stearns:
What, you don't like this?
You don't like The Hoff?
[song begins again]
Uh, and I'm not
really sure why,
but the YouTube logo
gets really big on this one
when it goes full screen.
But you can actually call
set size on the player,
and set it to the size,
and the logo should stay
the small size.
So he must be doing
something funky with that.
But you should be able
to get that fixed there.
So that's sort of an example
of the chromeless player.
So going full screen.
So, like, you can see this.
And if you were
to customize this player
to allow, you know,
to load new videos,
then you could have
a full screen player
that just always stays
full screen,
and just always loads
new videos as they sit there.
Hasselhoff singing:
How can you say that?
We've only just met.
Stearns: Yeah.
It's a good video.
You guys should watch that
at some point.
man: Is it possible to detect
the exit of the full screen?
Stearns: So is it possible
to detect the exit
of the full screen?
Yes, if you're using
Flash, you can.
Whatever the container
movie clip is,
there's an on full screen event
that gets fired,
and it tells you if it's
going into full screen
or exiting full screen.
man: What about in files
using JavaScript?
Stearns: No.
Our player doesn't have that
built in either.
[man speaking indistinctly]
Stearns: Right, I mean,
it could be as simple
as making a SWF that proxy's
the JavaScript calls
to the JavaScript
into our player
and that also has
the on full screen event handler
and, like, that's it.
So it would be
a pretty simple SWF
if that's all you wanted.
man: Would the events
that are defined by RealPlayer
be allocated out--
Stearns: You'd have
to do it yourself.
man: So we'd pretty much
have to recreate everything--
Stearns: Yeah, but that API's
not that big.
So it wouldn't be
that difficult.
There's another question
back there.
man: Yeah, what's the advantage
of using the chromeless player
[continues indistinctly]
Stearns: Um, well,
the difference is that
we don't allow people
to access our FLVs directly.
You have to jump
through a lot of hoops to do it.
And it's not supported by us,
and we really discourage it.
The reason being
is that we have--
We give a lot of users options
when they upload their videos.
Like, they'll only want this
to be available
in this country,
or maybe they only want their
friends to be able to see it.
And if you go
to the FLVs directly,
you bypass all of that.
So our players are, like,
the gateway.
So our players are sort of,
you know,
playing the cop
to our FLV things
to enforce people's options.
So you could in fact
piss off your users
if they went to your site
and you started playing
their private videos,
and they'd be like,
"What's wrong with you guys?"
So it's better to use
the chromeless player
or the embedded player.
And then we won't send you
nasty illegal letters either.
[laughter]
Small--small footnote there.
Um, any other questions
before we keep going?
All right, I'll leave some
time at the end for questions.
Actually, how much longer
do I have?
15 minutes.
I think so.
All right.
A few more examples.
This is a company
called Slide.
They do a lot
of Facebook apps and things.
They have a way that you can
customize the chromeless player
and then put it
on your site I think.
So they have, like, a bunch
of skins you can choose.
I like this one 'cause
it's got lots of bling.
Then you can, like,
pick a video you want.
And it basically
looks like this,
so you can have, like,
a custom player,
and it plays
in their player.
Whoops, this actually
makes you save it
before you can play it.
No, skip.
So here's my video,
and then I can hit play.
[man singing, crowd cheering]
Stearns: So that's about it
for that one.
Um, let's see.
Here's another example
of someone
who had made a custom UI
using all Flash.
So this is actually a SWF that
loads the chromeless player.
Again, sort of like
the JW FLV player.
And they have their own thing.
So what they have
is they have it set up
so you can actually pick
a YouTube user channel,
or user favorites,
or playlist, or whatever,
and then put in, you know,
either the user name
or maybe, like, a keyword,
I think, or something like that.
And it'll actually make you
a player
that you can embed
on your site.
And then that player
will play, like,
all your favorite videos,
or a specific user's videos
if you want.
So it's kinda cool.
So these are, like,
playing videos
from Big Cat Rescue.
One time I was showing this
at a talk,
and there was a video
of a tiger
carrying around
a severed cow head.
And it was really gross.
[laughter]
I just thought I would
share that with you guys.
woman: Like any youngster,
Hope just had to show off--
Stearns: That didn't look
like a big cat.
That looked
like a house cat.
All right, anyway,
one more quick thing.
This one was done by a guy
I used to work with
that I thought
was kinda neat.
There's a whole sort of--
Whoops, why is that there?
So there's this whole sort of,
uh, sort of subculture
on YouTube, I guess,
that videotape records
and 45s and things.
They put a camera and point it
at their 45 and play it.
So they have, like,
all this really cool, old,
like, reggae, and ska music,
and stuff.
[cat meows]
And apparently cats meowing.
I guess that's
on the record.
So he set this up so it's
sort of like a little,
like, a jukebox thing
where it'll play one thing.
And then when this is done,
it'll start playing
the other one automatically
and then load a new video.
And there's a few
different users where, like,
all their videos
are just this stuff.
So you can just pick
the username and then play it.
I thought this
was kinda neat.
And it uses, you know,
the volume.
And if you don't like a song,
you can just start playing
this one.
And then when this one
starts playing,
the other ones stops and--
I don't know,
it's kinda neat.
Really simple,
but interesting, I thought.
Um, all right,
so that's it.
So I was gonna do
a demo here really quick
of the JavaScript stuff,
but I think I went over it all.
So why don't we just jump
right to questions.
And then if you guys
have questions
about the JavaScript stuff,
I can answer them
and sort of
do the demo that way.
Question over here, yeah?
man: Sorry, I have
a JavaScript question.
Stearns: Oh, no problem.
man: I've seen some examples
of people putting
their own logos on the videos,
which I imagine is somewhat
of a sensitive topic.
What's the Google policy
on that?
Stearns: Um, so disclaimer.
I'm not a lawyer, obviously.
But, uh, if you're using
the chromeless player,
it's gonna have
our logo on it.
Or the embedded player's
gonna have our logo on it.
So usually if you see somebody
that's using that
with their own logo,
they're probably not using
one of our players.
So it's, like,
totally unsupported
by our terms of service,
and it's a violation of
our terms of service, I believe.
You know, unless they have
some special arrangement.
But to my knowledge,
I don't think we even do
special arrangements
like that.
So it's probably way bad.
Don't do it.
Any other questions?
In the very far back there,
yeah?
[man speaking indistinctly]
Stearns: So the question is what
kind of control do you have
over the bit rate the videos
are encoded at?
And the answer
is absolutely none.
YouTube encodes them
at our own bit rate,
so whatever we want
when the user uploads it.
If you look at
the YouTube site lately,
you'll notice that we do have
on some videos
a high quality mode.
So you can actually watch them
at a higher quality.
So I think the default size
is somewhere around
320x240 for, like, the small,
classic sort of YouTube sizes.
And then we have
bigger sizes from there.
And then you'll see different
sort of bigger quality stuff
on, like, iPhones
and Apple TVs and things.
But we don't, I believe,
don't give access to those
in the API stuff.
So at some point
down the road,
we will be adding high quality
to the embedded players,
but it's a matter
of seeing the feature
mature and stabilize
on the site first
before that happens.
The thing is that when we add
new features on the site,
we have to let them
sort of settle in.
'Cause if we add them
to the embedded player
and add them to the API,
then you guys get really mad
if we ever change them, right?
So we want them to be solid
before we push them
out to you guys
and you guys
start using them.
Any other questions?
Yeah, green shirt I think
had his hand up first.
man: So what's the policy
on displaying
in-video advertisements
embedded in--
Stearns: So the question is
what's the policy on embedded--
putting in-video advertising
on the players?
And I believe
it's totally forbidden.
man: So--
Stearns: You mean our policy
or can you do it?
man: No, your policy.
Stearns: Our policy.
I think we may at some point.
So I guess--I suppose
we reserve the right.
I think it's in the terms.
Nickeal could probably
answer that question
if you guys want to ask him
specific stuff.
And his talk's actually next.
And he'll be able to sort of
explain the terms of service
and give you some better--
Maybe?
No?
Nickeal's not a lawyer,
but he can--
But he knows it really well.
So feel free to ask him,
unless there's somebody better.
Is there anybody better
that's here?
No.
Nikeal's your man.
Go ask him.
Next question.
Uh, I don't know which one
was you first?
All right, go ahead.
man: Um, with a lot
of your examples
you showed exactly
what I was looking for
which was the time-based events.
If the key frame is not there,
is it still accurate such that--
I don't care
if there's a key frame or not.
But I do care that if
when I'm listening to it
that it tells the right time.
Stearns: Uh, it does.
So if you seek to 15
and it goes to 10,
it'll tell you
that it's at 10.
man: But if I'm listening
to see where it's at,
will I be told it's at ten
because there's no key frame?
Stearns: Um, you will--
Well, you're basically told
exactly where it's at.
So, like, whatever you're
seeing on the video
and whatever time that is,
that's what time the API says.
So if you tell it
to go to 15,
and there's
no key frame at 15,
but there is
a key frame at 12,
the player goes to 12
and the API tells you
that it went to 12.
man: And thus going forward
I'll know it's at 13, 14, 15?
Stearns: Right, right, right.
And then it goes up
from there as it goes.
Uh, yeah?
man: So I'm having problems
resizing the YouTube player
in Flash.
Stearns: Okay.
man: And I'm not sure exactly
when you're supposed
to do it.
[continues indistinctly]
Stearns: So I think there was
a bug about this
that I was tracking.
Are you the one that posted that
on the forum actually?
Somebody posted it.
The thing is
is that if you set up--
There was a bug in the player
where if you set an interval
to pull the player too often,
it was basically saying
it was ready before
it was actually ready.
man: Your example
was every two--
Stearns: Right,
I think in Flash
my example code was using
an on enter frame event,
and I think I was using, like,
31 frames per second or so.
And that was okay for me,
and I never saw the bug.
But I was able
to reproduce it,
and I think
I just fixed it yesterday.
So you'll probably see it
in a push next week probably.
So it should be fixed
next week.
And then you should be able--
as soon as you call--
As soon as the player's ready
you can call set size,
and it'll work.
Uh, another question
over here maybe?
man: Question,
with the chromeless player,
the whole video frame
becomes effectively a button.
You can click there
and it'll launch YouTube
to that video's homepage.
>> Stearns: Right.
man: My question, is there a way
to disable that or change that?
Stearns: No,
and I think it's part
of the terms of service
is that you have to have
a link back to YouTube.
So I think that's why
that's there.
man: All right, so I think
the following question
will probably be "no" as well.
But in the sharing menus,
the event code
could be link.
There's no way to control
the Google to that URL is there?
It's always back to YouTube.
Stearns: Yeah, it always goes
back to YouTube.
If you use
the chromeless player though,
it doesn't even have that.
So you could in theory
build your own link.
Like, in fact that
Rock Your Look site,
they actually when you get
a link to a video,
it gives you the link
to the Rock Your Look site
to the specific video
you were watching,
not to YouTube.
Uh, another question?
[man speaking indistinctly]
Stearns: Yeah, okay.
As long as you're, you know,
nice to us, it's cool.
There was another question
back there I think, yeah?
man: Yeah, are there any plans
for an ActionScript 3 player--
Stearns: Um, yes, but it's
probably still some time away.
man: What's that next version
of ActionScript?
[continues indistinctly]
Stearns: Yeah, ActionScript 3
is, like, the latest version.
It's a different--
it's not compatible with AS 2,
which is what our players
are written in.
So you have to have
a new version.
Any more questions?
Do you guys wanna watch
more Billoon videos?
[laughter]
There's a question
in the back there.
man:
Question on the frame size.
When we upload a video
that is set in wide-screen,
can we, in the chromeless,
show that in its true size?
Stearns: Um, you can.
Um.
It's a recent thing
where YouTube
used to force all videos
to be 4x3.
And I believe there's been
a recent change
to where we don't
do that anymore,
but I don't know
if it's every video
or only, like,
certain popular videos.
I'm not exactly sure.
We are moving
in that direction though.
So very soon,
if not already,
you will be able
to upload, like,
a 16x9 video and it'll stay
at whatever aspect ratio
you upload it at.
So the players,
including the embedded player
and the chromeless player,
are set up in a way
that you basically set
the viewport size,
and then the video,
no matter what the aspect ratio
of the video is,
it just tries to fill up
as much of the space
that you give it as possible.
So if, like, the video is--
If you set
the chromeless player
to be 16x9
and the video is 4x3,
you'll just automatically
get black bars
on the left and right side.
Same thing if it's, like,
you know,
a really tall
and skinny video.
You'll get black bars
on the, you know, the side.
I should say bars on the top
and bottom, I guess.
Or, yeah.
You guys know what I mean.
Another question.
man: The videos that were
uploaded, say,
six months ago have
the resolution of DVD encoding?
Stearns: Um, they may be,
but I don't know.
We have a lot of videos,
so it could take a while.
Um, but it's something
that I would like to do.
So it could take a while,
but, yes.
Another one in the back?
[man speaking indistinctly]
Stearns: Uh, that's a good
question, and I don't know.
Um...
Oh, so the question was that--
Do all of the videos get encoded
at the same bit rate,
or do we sort of sense
the quality of the video
and then encode it
at a lower bit rate?
Um, I think that
for the high-quality stuff
we sort of check and see
if the video
would actually benefit
from being high-quality.
Like, if somebody uploads
a crappy source version,
we might not waste time making
a high-quality version of it,
'cause it wouldn't really help.
But I think, like,
the standard, you know,
320x240 size,
I'm not actually sure
if it's a standard bit rate
for all of them.
It might be a good question
to ask--
Actually, I don't know
who would know that.
Probably some of the engineers.
Which one?
You think John?
Yeah, John would know.
If you see John Harding
out front,
the guy that did the talk first,
he may know that.
Um, any other questions?
Last chance.
Okay, I will be around,
in the lobby probably,
for the rest of the time.
I think we have a break
right now for about 15--
19 minutes or something,
'cause we're stopping
a little bit early,
so feel free to wander out.
Go to the bathroom.
Get a snack.
Uh, thanks for coming.
[applause]